So let's talk about the feasibility of the
vision of active networks. The reality is, router
makers like Cisco are loath to opening of
the network. So while the idea of active networks
is very fascinating, that we can be frugal
about the resources that we use in the Internet
for different network flows and we can actually
virtualize the physical infrastructure by slapping on. Our own
idea of what should be the, the kind of
network flow that I want for my packets, seems very
attractive, but really it's not going to be feasible given that
we have to open up the network. So it's going to
be feasible only at the edge of the network.
Secondly, when we are using active networks, we are talking
about executing code in a router in order to determine
the routing decision at that node. Or in other words,
we're doing software routing. Software routing cannot match the hardware
routing, because at the core of the network, there's so
much of traffic being handled that you really want to do
this in hardware, and doing this at software speed is
not going to match the hardware speed of packet processing in
the core of the network. So once again, this argues
that active network is only feasible at the edge of
the network and finally there are social and psychological reasons why
active networks is maybe a little bit hard to
digest. It is hard for the user community to
accept arbitrary code executing in a public routing fabric.
If my traffic is flowing through the network and if
the router is going to actually execute some code in
order to do the processing of my packet, that
worries me. Already, we talk a lot about privacy
and the fact that in corporate networks, in university networks,
we are losing a lot of privacy. People
are watching what's going on. And now, saying that
the routers are going to do something intelligent, a smart
processing packets, that might be a socially and psychologically
unacceptable proposition. So these are reasons why it would
make it difficult to sell the idea of active
networks to the wide area internet. On the other
hand, the idea of virtualizing the network flow is
very appealing. And if you put together the two thoughts that I had,
one is the idea that we can virtualize the network and the second that
active networks is only feasible at the edge of the network, that brings up
a very interesting proposition, which I am
going to mention in my concluding remarks.